[Music]
hey everyone and welcome to theories and
Thrones and today we're talking all
about episode four of Game of Thrones
final season the last of the Starks I'm
Liana Giller from Entertainment Tonight
and I'm Mike reserve from GameSpot we
are excited to start hearing all of your
thoughts about last night's episode
because we have a lot to discuss we have
so much to discuss but as always before
we get started this is an after show so
you shouldn't be here until you've
watched the episode because we're
getting into spoilers all the spoilers
so many spoilers
now we're gonna be discussing the two
big deaths of the night the romantic
rollercoaster ride of Jaime and Brienne
John and Danny is not so secret secret
and so much more so start sending us
your questions comments and theories
because we're dying to know your
thoughts you know we asked et's fans on
Twitter what you all thought of the
episode and it was Plitt pretty split
yeah 45 percent of people who responded
said you loved this episode well 55
percent said it was not your favorite
your favorite well what did you guys
think tell me and Mike I've got to know
what are your quick thoughts about the
episode I'm torn on this one I didn't
hate it yeah like like last week there
was some some tense scenes and I
appreciate a lot of the things that
they're trying to do on multiple levels
there's a lot going on I do have some
complaints as well what about you sorry
I just realized Mike your coffee cup has
been in the shot this entire time Oh God
how could you do that
this is embarrassing like the fact that
yes you guys apparently Starbucks has
come to Winterfell because we got our
very own cup in last night's episode
let's take a look at that moment because
I loved the fact that there we are at
the feast of Winterfell everyone's
having a really good time and then
tormund goes over and in the back you
see that danny has a starbucks cup right
it's on the table in front of her it's
on the table
right hard to miss once you see it I'm
one of the people that finds continuity
errors really hilarious because it makes
me feel way better about all of my
mistakes
oh man of this one I just think it's
hilarious that they were working on this
for two years
yeah two years I think people are seeing
it sort of as a tiny microcosm of the
general kind of decline and attention to
detail for the show which I don't know I
you can look at it that way I don't know
if that's fair because that's fair we're
all human we make mistakes
I mean look they're creating dragons out
of thin air Danny's gonna have a pumpkin
spice latte I'm okay with it
you're gonna stay caffeinated I relate
yeah but you know what I really did
enjoy this episode so much more than the
Battle of Winterfell especially because
we finally had some impactful deaths
which leads us to the biggest question
of every Game of Thrones episode who
died who died first up Fraggle died
Reagle died that's John's dragon ah he
is done that's it lucky you called it
John's dragons John's John's is named
after his dad okay the one that he rode
yes and if you were like me looking
forward to the end game of this series
for years and years and years
the theory always was that would be that
would be dragon so the fact that they
took him out with three quick shots I
can't like can we complain about that
scene for a second because there I have
so many okay so before you complain
about it I've got to say I did not see
it coming
oh yeah I feel a little robbed that
happened so quickly however because it
was so fast it broke my heart so quickly
that I I hate to say that I enjoyed it
but I didn't see it coming and I respect
that
it was shocking it was shocking it was
surprising I I was not but my problem
with the scene is is partially the way
that it's shot with the camera looking
up at the sky we can't tell what we're
shooting at them and where these people
when did these ships come into view yes
and how did she not see them she's
flying above everyone else
I think the like at the beginning of
that scene she was flying she was
excited she's like I'm on my babies
she's distract and then and then right
here.we is where we start to see that
they go around this giant mountain and
that's where everyone was hiding the way
that it's shot it feels like it's like
they were hiding it feels like the ships
shot ragel before they could possibly
have a view yes they have line of sight
on the Dragons the dragon should have
line of sight on them
and that shouldn't have happened yeah
but beyond that you know I I can't
believe that nobody anticipated this
attack like this show gets the geography
of Westeros wrong so often but one thing
they get right is that dragon sowed in
King's Landing our stone's throw away
from each other share you know that Bay
on the the east coast of Westeros so the
fact that nobody thought that there
might be in the post in the post episode
featurette David and Dan essentially say
you know Danny kind of forgot about the
iron fleet what Danny forgot about the
iron fleet and Varys in Tyrion and John
and great everybody else forgot about
the iron fleet that's bad that's bad
writing I I will stick with that I'm sad
that it happened but I'm surprised that
it happened but I do think that the more
I think about it I'm like how did that
happen I'm okay that it happened I don't
like the way that it happened yeah there
let's talk about our next big death
missed Sunday yes miss Sunday r.i.p miss
sunday feel about this um i am excited
that we have this sounds really awful
i'm excited that we have an impactful
death that is gonna propel Danny and a
lot of our characters forward did that
did that feel more impactful to you than
Theon and Jorah all these other days
because in the Battle of Winterfell we
were braced we are like this is gonna be
the episode we're gonna lose so many
people and it wasn't until the very end
that we were like Jorah okay we can lose
Jorah Fionna okay we can lose Theon and
then we're like that's it and it didn't
have any of that impactful moment of
like this is gonna change and this is
gonna change something in the story bark
something in Danny and then this is also
I think going to be the catalyst to
getting the audience back behind her
because we can discuss this more in a
little bit but yeah I'm one of the
people that like I've been rooting for
Danny I've been on this journey with her
for seven seasons as a girl it's been
fun to see her like really step up and
be like I'm taking back what's
rightfully mine that's my brother guy
it's been fun to see her I've always
rooted for Danny but there's this
there's been this weird shift in the
past season and a half where I'm not
supposed to root for Danny and it feels
like they're cheating she doesn't feel
earned
my question about this we're seeing to
see now my question about this scene
Searcy grabs Miss Andy's arm oh yeah
right says to have any last words right
miss Andy knows she's gonna die and Miss
Andy is a badass I think we have seen in
the show before why doesn't it Sadie not
grab Searcy back and plunge over the
edge yeah she clearly wasn't changed she
falls down right there to me like all
these characters are not acting they're
acting as if they are characters in
service to a plot and they're not acting
true to the characters themselves like
in this scene again I want to ask you
guys a question began I cannot figure
this out and I am I am dying for
somebody to give me an explanation that
I can get behind
why did Cersei not just kill them all
right there we saw in the previous scene
that the range of the scorpions is
ridiculous yeah they were like oh yeah
and they're all white why would Cersei
let Tyrion and Dany and the last dragon
walk away from that encounter I cannot
think of a reason why Cersei would let
them go we're starting to get in so many
great fan comments right now randon said
hopefully in the sunday's savage death
shows that complainers don't know
everything if you killed grey worm last
episode you don't have the same powerful
snake slash motivation to raise the city
and I think that's a really great point
I was really confused last week as to
why grey worm survived that episode and
it was so that we could absolutely miss
send a die and have that really fuel him
and lead what's left of the unsullied to
charge forth into the city I made this
moment better exactly um so many other
people oh-ee nesaja says drew chorus
let's talk about the fact that that was
her final word it was good did you see
the actress yes she tweeted out your
chorus and then she goes aka burn the
[ __ ] so good like you know I'm a fan of
that actress yes yeah her tone is great
I thought it was really great in the
beach um I think it's now let's keep the
conversation going with the other big
moments of the episode with oMG G ot
first up we've got to talk about my
personal favorite storyline arc of the
episode I'm sorry I'm such a big REO
stand but you know what
Arya Stark is not your lady she's she's
not your lady she never
I've been your lady Gendry vastly
misjudged this moment I think Aria was
using you for your hot blacksmith body
and does not need literally he wanted to
get laid before the battle she liked him
she had a crush on him but the fact that
he went up to her and was like I think
you're beautiful I don't know how to be
a lord be my lady like I care about you
so much it was of course I knew she was
not going to accept the proposed I was a
little bit worried when she when he did
it and she right here she leaned down a
kiss in my wind I literally sitting on
my couch and standing back up to end the
proposal and I loved that that was a
real great that we let him down Jimmy I
was like chef K is perfect but so
obviously Aria is not going to be the
lady of storms end right and she has
unfinished business right she and Sandor
yeah I'm heading south they're heading
south oh no where they're going I loved
as soon as we see him leaving and he
looks up and he sees her and I'm just
like yes we have our arya and hound
reunion their interactions to me are so
wonderful i feel like he really treats
her as his equal now yeah and their
their their storyline back in season 4
season 3 season 4 whatever I mean it's a
fan favorite and so in a way this was a
fan Servicing moment yeah but I feel
like it was one that was earned and also
one that actually works for the
characters works for going forward what
they're going to do you know she has two
names left on her list he has one yeah
and there's some overlap there so there
is some overlap I never thought about
Arya and the Hound teaming up for
cleganebowl but I am here for it movie
night said Kendriya with a heart
Gendry has no more yeah you still shift
that which I still ship that I still
okay I know that it'll never happen or
cuz until she crosses her net last name
off her list but if she one day like he
wouldn't make her wear a dress like sure
I feel like that specifically the word
choice of Lady would be a problem I'm
not picturing Gendry like sadly walking
down those storms end I'm just kind of
the castles empty he goes inside and he
went home and he's just there alone
whatever Donna says I don't know why
Arya left Winterfell after her speech
about family with John we're gonna be
getting to that in just a little bit
yeah next up let's talk about
breanne and jamie's rollercoaster
romance the fact that there were some
ups and downs you had a lot of ups and
downs let's start off with the fact that
once Danny announced the Gendry was
going to be the Lord of storms end and
really kind of gave him his title the
night turned into a big party Brianne
got rung we've never seen I mean that
drinking game was fun that drinking game
was fun I really enjoyed it and I liked
that it was a through-line that we've
seen throughout it but then it led to
this pivotal moment of Jamie
acknowledging his feelings for Brienne
or giving her a gift how did you feel
about this what did you think I think
that it was so sweet and I think that
this is something that that Brienne I
don't want to say deserves but seeing
her get to be with Jamie this woman this
man that she has loved for such a long
time and getting her to have this moment
was so wonderful it but what worries me
is that he might not feel the same about
her and that's clear once he decided
that he needed to leave yeah after Kings
well I to me this was the the wrong kind
of fan service to me it felt it felt a
little bit gratuitous but only because
in Episode two when he knighted her was
such a perfect moment perfect I almost
wanted that to be their special but that
to me was the perfect culmination of
their character arcs yeah intersecting
for what should have been the final time
and it wasn't in the way that so many
fans had hope yes it was surprising but
it worked on a thematic and on a
character level and I wish they had just
left it at that I saw a lot of tweets
last night who were upset when Brienne
was crying when Jamie left and if we
take a look at that scene Brienne is
obviously very upset that Jamie is
choosing to leave her because he was
going to be staying in Winterfell for
her she thought that she had found her
to be at fairytale happily ever after
but when he says that he's drawn to
Cersei either in a he's gonna kill her
kind of way right yeah we talked about
that or in the fact that he's just as
bad as her but a lot of fans were saying
they were really upset to see her crying
saying that Brienne should be a strong
woman she doesn't need a man like why
are we watching her cry and I think why
not watch her car yeah I don't I don't
buy that I don't think that's a good I
don't think that's a good
she's a strong woman but you can still
feel your feelings
she's a strong character for like she's
also a complex character she has so many
dimensions and layers and to see her
finally break down because she thinks
that one mound she loves
she's gotten what she not just what she
want to move yes something she thought
she would never have jinkx I'm fine with
it
I am okay with it I'm okay with it
everyone's heartbroken in the comments
right now though so we feel your pain um
you know it really made my heart break
last night and let's talk about it the
fact that Jon Snow is the worst pet
owner in the realm Jon Snow should not
be allowed to adopt any more dogs no no
not at all
let's talk about the fact that he has
been with ghosts since ghosts was a
little pump a little pup and the fact
that I I appreciate the fact that
torment is like I'm taking the free
Foulke and I'm getting the hell out of
here my battles done thank you so much I
mean sense that totally made sense but
the fact of it John was like by the way
take my dog did you take my dog just
like I don't feel I have a dragon now
and I don't really feel like watching
him anymore the facts but first of all I
was so thrilled to see that Ghost
survived the Battle of Winterfell he's
missing an ear he's clearly definitely
gone for some love he got her he's a
good good boy and I've seen this I've
seen this sentiment a lot which is that
ghost is a good good boy yeah and I he
deserved some pets and scratches and
Watson smooches why could he got nothing
it was sunset I know that he'll get love
with torment but look and then he he
says goodbye ghost wants to go look over
at Tarzan what does that face say to you
that face says to you I don't care about
this I'm like I understand that it took
a lot of the CGI budget to kill ray Gogh
I guess it came back to my face like
like so hateful I am so upset that that
is how we left ghosts that the fact that
John is not gonna take ownership is not
going to even be like stay with Sansa
let me let me be like you've been such a
good boy you've saved my life so many
times I'm sorry I'm upset and so is axe
axe aka aks says I will never understand
how John is so disrespectful towards
ghosty my heart broke for ghost the way
he looked so upset in my my head I need
to keep the book
Hannan's straight and the book Canon is
that john loves ghost and he is always
by his side except when you know he
physically can't be because they're
separated by the wall when he's with the
wildlings or whatever various points but
at all times when it's possible it goes
his by his side because to me this is a
symptom of the David and Dan the
showrunners the writers of this episode
and many episodes before just not
understanding the symbolism and what the
direwolves represent time and time again
killed the dire wolves they just he just
sends him away without a just needed I
know how to talk to him I needed him to
I'm sorry I'm very bad me too it's it's
it's symbolic of John leaving his stark
identity behind yeah bro I appreciate
the symbolism but the fact that they the
show did not give more weight to that
moment indicate to me that they don't
which leads us into the worst kept
secret in Westeros the fact that John
and Danny are related John finally
decides to tell his sisters or his
cousins they my god John decides to let
Sansa and Arya in on the secret but my
big issue with the scene is once again I
understand that it would take up time
for us to rehash this information that
we know but the fact that John just
looks at Brandon he's like tell him and
we didn't get to see that and we didn't
get just that there was such a huge just
slap in my face like I have been waiting
to see Arya react to learning about
John's true identity Arya and John have
a special bond it's present in the show
they were the outsiders of the family
for various reasons they always
identified most closely with one another
and arias whole thing in this scene is
about family and the fact that we did
not get to see the way that she reacts
to learning this news is a crime it's a
Travis and it's one of those things
where a lot of fan support for this
season has been it's been so great to
see these conversations between
characters because it's paid off because
we know their relationship so well and
we know their dynamic yeah and the fact
that we were a robbed of that was really
crazy and this episode is I think 78
minutes long yeah make it seventy eight
and a half minutes long and show me
let me see that and I love the fact that
Sansa so John goes swear that you will
not tell anyone Sean sits like I totally
swear crossing my fingers and then she's
like Tyrion medially and Tyrion this
makes sense for Sansa because as many
people have pointed out calculators oh
she's doing student of Littlefinger and
Cersei and watching these people who are
manipulative yeah so the first thing she
does is starts manipulating people Tyler
says Sansa is up to something I think
the fact that Sansa is just looking out
for her family and doesn't trust Danny I
feel like that is finally yummy we
disagree on this because for me their
whole thing in the earlier episode of
the season was that Danny needed to do
something that would prove to the
northerners that she is worthy of their
support yes and she did she sacrificed
half of her forces at least I mean it
looked like all the Dothraki died
apparently they didn't anyway
she sacrificed half of her forces to
defend their home and Sansa is still
unbelievably cold to her and it feels
like i like i appreciate the direction
that it's going
I feel like the writing this season has
not earned has not earned this I feel
like it's not justified for Sansa to be
so dismissive of her still I liked the
fact that Santa is still distrustful of
Dany because it led to Sansa telling to
you're in the secret she then we then
saw that Tyrion then told Varys right
and we can see in that scene that you
know the cracks are starting to form
within Danny's small council it's
getting smaller and smaller now that
Jorah and Messiah are gone she's really
left with Tyrion who you and I've talked
about this thinks that John and Danny
should just get married everything's
fine embarrasses happy of course we all
want that to happen but Varys is being
you know he's looking out for the good
of the realm the good of the realm I
object because I don't it's not that I
want that to happen
okay it's that I think that it's the
most logical thing to happen yeah it
makes the most sense because it's the
easiest it's the smartest Danny ditched
Daario and marine so that she could come
to Westeros I have a strong marriage
alliance yeah there is no stronger
marriage alliance than John who is half
Targaryen half Stark has the full
support of the north everybody loves him
yeah and the smartest thing is to unite
and form a new Targaryen dynasty and to
Tirion brings it up and Varys dismisses
it out of hand he says oh that wouldn't
work and then they quickly move on and I
appreciate again I appreciate the
conflict this is building toward but I
feel like the writing isn't there to
support why they can't just do it you
know
the most obvious way yeah we're starting
to creep into theories territory so
let's fully dive into your questions
comments and theories because you guys
have been blowing up our comments
section right now and I love seeing all
of you guys
Lucia says I wanted to break my TV when
they didn't show Sansa and Arya is
response to the truth about John well
Lucia you might need to break your TV
because according to the cinematographer
for last week's episode it was your
fault that your TV was not good enough
to see the episode which I still am a
little bitter on the fact that it was
dark and there right so so maybe it's
our fault that we didn't get to see that
conversation yeah maybe
movie night says where is Nymeria and
her pack this is a really good question
I wanted to see ghost go off with
Nymeria I was hoping that he would get
hurt and then not hurt in the battle but
he did and I was hoping that they would
anyway it would be with John and Arya
you know I guess growing apart their
wolves to get together I think would be
some nice symbolism but erikak railing
says torment dog sitter extraordinaire I
mean torment you didn't get the girl you
got the dog yeah sometimes that's you
know sometimes that's better
sometimes that's way better what do you
guys think yeah now that Rangel and
Miss Andy are dead is Danny gonna go
full Mad Queen this is one of the one of
the choices my speculation game for
Danny gonna go mad Queen I am okay with
it yeah do you think she is I think that
she's about to get a little unhinged I
feel like it's rightfully earned no I so
we're in full agreement she is going
full mad queen yeah and I support that i
they've been dropping the little hints
obviously when she burned up Samuel
Charlie's father and brother we got that
little hint of it we've seen more of the
fact that like Sansa called out Tyrion
is like were terrified of her and he of
course tries to gloss it over and be
like every good rulers inspire fear you
know I think he has a point like it I
think that maybe this is not popular but
Danny burning
you know the tarly's I thought I was
totally chill with it would be Donnelly
yeah and the need she has a dragon you
don't need to be executed right now yeah
she they did not give her a choice and
so I think that all of these decisions
that she has made yeah are justified and
I think for Varys to turn on her the
first time she makes a decision that he
doesn't agree with is so not in keeping
with various his character it's another
thing that they haven't earned I do
think it is keeping with his character
Varys is the spider he said to her face
I will be the first person to tell you
when I don't like what you're doing he
has betrayed how many kings now yeah I
do think that this is a venters's
character I think that I don't agree
with his interests of looking out for
the realm but I do think that he's the
first person to be like hi John would be
a better ruler and truthfully at this
point I don't agree because John is
driving me nuts but yeah I to me like I
don't know when I was supposed to stop
rooting for Danny to show up and burn
her enemies to the ground I have been
waiting for this like that anger that
has been bubbling towards Cersei over
the seasons as she continues to just be
horrible yeah over and over I want Danny
I want fire and blood that's what I want
a Legree says burn them all with a bunch
of fire emojis yes yes um obviously
Tyrians main concern was let's let's
protect the people of the keep they are
gonna be your loyal subjects let's try
and spare their lives but now with this
happening it's clear that Cersei doesn't
care about the people and maybe now
Danny doesn't care about the people
either what are your thoughts on that
and the fact that literally burn them
all I mean I think that Cersei blew up a
huge chunk of her city already and so -
if we have to burn if it's a war right
there's casualties and I think that it
is worth it to wrest control away from
Cersei I think that Varys and Sansa
everybody's scheming and plotting right
now john versus Danny this is a conflict
that they are creating within their own
ranks they are self sabotaging at the
eleventh hour when they should be
unified
and yeah just I think they should be
smarter than this they should come up
with another solution besides I mean to
me varus insinuated that he is gonna
have Danny assassinated like when Tyrion
said you know what is the solution that
was Varys said essentially don't make me
answer that question like that's your
solution dude if he's okay
Varys plotting to assassinate Danny good
luck with that but if he's gonna frame
Tyrion for it that's when I have an
issue
I'm says yeah that's what I'm worried
about about that doctor I think abouts
is says they all hate on Danny who
wouldn't react like who blamed me act
like that yeah seriously played them all
yeah killed Rhaegar she killed miss Andi
I was landed yeah that's what I do I
mean is now the time should an active
democracy in King's Landing like hey
guys before you died you just want to
Danny fly into King's Landing under
cover of darkness when the scorpions
can't see you go straight to the Red
Keep and just roast it just burn it to
the ground that's what I say I mean I
would also like to point out that that I
don't think anybody has given us a
satisfactory answer as to why Cersei did
not just kill them all when they were
standing right outside you know outside
her gate or why Miss Sunday didn't just
push her off the ledge there are a lot
of things that I that I think I could
have gone differently in this episode
here is a cool theory fino says I think
Daenerys is pregnant watched the first
scene of the fifth episode preview I did
I did see that um
I mean she's down to babies so maybe
it's time to give her another one what
do we think speaking of pregnancies what
do you think about Circe's pregnancy
goodness gracious I don't care i I was
anticipating to say that but at this
point like I don't care about service
pregnancy I think it's because for the
longest time you and I didn't even
believe that it happened and then and
then for charity be like I'm sorry about
your baby like please think of the baby
and then you're on tour over there just
like with his maniacal grin like I'm so
excited
Lucas in the background of that scene
yeah to me the one thing that doesn't
track about that to me is that look at
the number of people who have like gone
north to King's Landing and come back
down
that is a long journey or gone north -
to Winterfell
Kings link that's a long journey sir she
should at least be a couple of months
pregnant at this point yes so to me
she's either lying or she's planning to
kill your on before you know if she is a
baby seven month dresses just loose
because you know gillies preggers and
nobody knew until John hugged her right
I thought I liked that I thought it was
really sweet I didn't need say I'm
having to like explain the other thing
about about Circe's pregnancies is I I
wish we had gotten a year on reaction
shot when Tyrion was trying to play that
card against Cersei yeah because Cersei
just told Euron about it yeah Tyrion is
that you didn't even tell your own about
assertion you just let your on be with
her and then stir ons the one that says
I'm gonna put a prince in your belly but
Cersei said this episode yeah she said
this episode you know our child or so
she's definitely using it I play against
yeah you're on
and how would Tyrion know about I don't
think you're on smart enough to put the
two together right I just think that
you're on is just so excited to be
included another thing that I want to
point out is the fact that I want
cleganebowl yeah it to me it's it's the
I may be the only thing I am looking
forward to still in the show because to
me what the episode what what the series
was really about died last episode and
I've ranted about this a lot but it to
me was always about this supernatural
force of nature threat bearing down on
humanity we have to put our squabbles
aside we have to band together and that
is the theme of the series and instead
they dispatched that and now we're back
to the battle for the most uncomfortable
seat in the world and I don't care about
that here's the one question that I'm
gonna leave you with him leave the fans
with who will kill Cersei if she dies
because we now have three contenders we
have Jaime heading back to King's
Landing
we have Arya and she's still the number
one on her list and we have Danny
because she's about to go full mad queen
or so it seems
yeah which person do you think who do
you think will kill and who do you wish
would kill yeah those are good questions
because as far as think I'm done making
predictions about this show I have no
idea I hope that it is Jamie because
that's a they left that when he left
Brienne they left it ambiguous
I had aria not killed the night king I
would have said I hope it's aria
but because she got to have that moment
I feel like she doesn't get to also kill
Cersei I feel like it's going to end up
being Jane Tyrion yeah it could be too
it could be a lot of people I I hope
it's somebody I hope it is more
narrative Lee fulfilling than already
killing the night king which was a
surprise but I would argue not earned I
want to bring up what I wanna bring up
what in says Davos is the only woke one
he's the only one to bring up the Lord
of Light the one that orchestrated all
of this I fully agreed yeah to me the
whole the red faith yeah the lore and
the Lord of Light and the prince that
was promised it's just a story thread
that has been dropped as far as I can
tell I wouldn't be surprised if they
never bring that up again in this I mean
are there no other disciples I think the
Hound is still a disciple of Lord of
Light this is this is actually my big
theory first of all that I'm real I said
I was done making predictions but this
is the way the game ball is the one
thing that I care about still and I
think I think the Hound you know fully
embracing the faith of the Lord of Light
yes into him would embody getting over
his I was gonna say his fear of fire and
his fear of fire as he does you know he
does the the fire sword and because
Gregor his brother burned his face with
fire when they were kids so it's it's a
lot of narrative things kind of coming
full circle yeah so I I do hope that
happens I hope a lot of things happen
but I cannot believe that we only have
two episodes left I think we're gonna
end it there yeah thank you all so much
for tuning in today be sure to join us
for theories and Thrones every Monday
morning at 8 a.m. West Coast and 11 a.m.
east coast for the next two episodes I
can't believe it but next week we're
gonna be breaking down the penultimate
episode that is the second-to-last
episode of Game of Thrones ever and as
always we're gonna include your comments
your thoughts your theory isn't about
the final two episodes noises tweet us
your thoughts any time tell us who you
think it's gonna kill Cersei we would
love to know maybe we'll do a poll and
we'll include it next time I'm still
waiting for somebody to explain to me
why Cersei didn't just roast them all at
the end very true very true
talk to you guys soon thanks so much bye
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]